BORIS: We're ready
to start here.
MALE SPEAKER: Yep,
go ahead and start.
It's been recording.
BORIS: OK, great.
So welcome everybody.
This is a small NASA
Ames SETI Institute
talk we have here today.
Chris McKay pinged me over
email a couple of weeks
ago regarding this topic,
and I think it's worthwhile.
So I'm going to let Chris
introduce Dale Anderson, who
by the way is one of the oldest
bloggers on the internet.
You'll hear about that.
Give a warm welcome
to both of them.
CHRIS MCKAY: Thanks Boris.
As Boris said, I'm at Ames
just across the creek.
You guys are engulfing us.
You may have noticed that.
And we're involved
in planetary science,
exploring other worlds.
And one of the ways we
do that is exploring
places on Earth
that are analogs.
And Dale has been one
of the leaders in that.
In particular the
application to Antarctica,
and diving in lakes, ice
covered lakes in Antarctica.
And he'll talk about
how that connects.
And we use a variety of
Google tools in what we do,
and mapping out what we're
doing, and researching.
Boris and I have had a
longstanding interaction
on shared interests ranging from
rovers to desert environments.
And two months ago,
three months ago,
Boris pinged me and
said, what are you guys
doing in Antarctica?
So that was the genesis of this.
Dale is actually
located in New York.
He's here for a week.
And so this was an opportunity
to come and sort of talk
a little bit about
what we're doing.
So Dale.
DALE ANDERSON: Thanks Chirs.
Thanks Boris.
Boris I'll probably
need a little help
getting this going again.
So I need to connect this
window back up right.
So back up here to Screen Share.
Screen Share, Desktop.
Yeah.
BORIS: That's where
we see the slides.
DALE ANDERSON: OK, where
has the application gone?
OK, we're good to go?
OK, great.
Well, thanks everybody
for showing up.
I appreciate it.
And what I want to do is
just by quick introduction
I am Dale Anderson.
I work over at the SETI
Institute at the Carl Sagan
Center.
And I do look at life
in extreme environments,
and I'll take you on a journey
to see some of those areas.
Again, basically at
the SETI Institute
we're interested in the
field of astrobiology,
and these bigger questions
of how did we get here,
where are we going,
and are we alone?
Are there microbial
ecosystems out in the universe
besides the ones we
find on Earth, or even
perhaps intelligent life that
we can hear through the radio
signals or other means?
And then we have
quite a few people
that work in a whole
slew of different areas.
It's a very
multi-disciplinary approach
to understanding the origins,
evolution, and distribution
of life in the universe.
So we're interested
in following the birth
of the biogenic
elements in the stars
all the way up through the
evolution of advanced life.
And so we have to have knowledge
of both things out in space,
and in particular we need
to have those lessons
that we learned here on Earth.
And of course, for us
right now, since we're not
going to be able to get
out beyond the solar system
anytime soon we're most
interested in trying
to find life here in our own
neighborhood, places like Mars,
and some of the outer moons
or outer planetary moons
like Europa,
Enceladus, and Titan.
So a little bit about me
and how I got to where I am.
I've been working in remote
environments like this
since I was 22.
And that was back
in 1978, so I've
been doing this for
a pretty good while.
I've got about 17
seasons in Antarctica,
60 plus months camped out
in these areas over my life.
Another 30 field seasons or
so up north, with another 30
months up there.
So I've spent a lot of
time sleeping in the rocks,
and have gotten pretty
comfortable at it,
and really enjoy doing
that kind of work.
And I've been able
over the years
to help develop a
lot of techniques
that we use to work
in these environments,
particularly the diving
under the thick ice
and putting the methods
together for studying
those environments.
And that's what I'm going to
talk about a little bit today.
Let's see.
So I can't really point to
this very easily, can I?
OK.
So here's the map of
Antarctica, and we're
going to go to basically
two different areas.
I've had the
privilege of working
in three major areas
of the Antarctic.
Down in the bottom
part of the screen
you'll see McMurdo
Sound, and that's
where the US Antarctic program
and the New Zealand programs
have their biggest research
programs going, right
around Ross Island and
the McMurdo Dry Valleys.
Also I've worked over in the
Bunger Hills, which is over
on the right hand
side of the screen.
This is another ice free area.
Back in 1991, '92, I was
part of a joint expedition
between the Soviet space program
and the US space program.
We spent about six and
a half, seven months
traversing around the Antarctic
continent by ice breaker,
and then getting dropped off
in the Bunger Hills for four,
four and a half months.
It was almost like
a Mars simulation.
You know, have an international
group of researchers,
mostly Russian and
American, one Canadian,
live together and work
together, and get over
those cultural difficulties
and language barriers just
as you would if you were on
Mars for a period of about
three years.
Really kind of a trip.
So this was a great expedition
to do exobiology work
with out Soviet counterparts.
More recently I've started
working with Chris and Alfonso.
Up in the top part
of the screen you'll
see that where the arrow is
going up to Lake Untersee,
this is down below South Africa.
There's an area there called
the Schirmacher Oasis.
And then you go further inland
and you'll hit some mountains.
And this is where the lake
that we're studying is located.
But I want to start this off
in the McMurdo Dry Valleys.
This is down in the Ross Island
region, south of New Zealand,
and this is were I cut my teeth
in the Antarctic back in 1978
starting as an undergrad.
Let me just back this up.
So the McMurdo Dry Valleys
are the largest ice free area
in the Antarctic continent.
It's only about 1% of the
continent is actually ice free.
So it's a very rare
type of environment.
It's a very cold, dry place.
And it's probably the
best terrestrial analog
that we have on
the planet to Mars.
And that's one of the things
that has drawn researchers
there, even from
the early 1960s.
JPL and Ames both had
researchers going down there
to prepare for the Viking
Program for example.
These were cold
deserts that they
wanted to understand how to look
for microbiology at the time.
So if you look very
closely in these values
you'll see next to
the glaciers you'll
see some ice covered bodies.
And those are small
lakes in the valleys.
And that's where
we're going to be
doing some of our work
in a little while.
Back in 1977 George
Simmons, who's
standing above me
while I'm getting
ready to jump in to
Lake Bonney here,
asked this very interesting
and important question
when he got out to these lakes.
Traditionally people had
only drilled small holes
through the thick
ice covers, cause
the ice covers are anywhere from
3 and 1/2 to 6 meters thick.
So that's a lot of
ice that you have
to go through to
get to the water.
Traditionally people
had drilled holes
through those with a
small jiffy drill, which
is a 20 centimeter, ten
inch bit to get through,
but nobody ever looked at
the bottom of the lakes.
Most of the work was done
in the water columns looking
at the phytoplankton and things
that are growing in the water.
But nobody actually
asked the question
what's growing on the bottom?
Most people thought
probably nothing,
we'll probably just find
rocks, because light
is going to be a limiter.
The light has to
penetrate through the ice
and go down to the bottom
to support photosynthesis,
and most people thought that
the light levels were just
going to be simply too low.
Simmons asked that
question, and it's funny
because back in
those days we didn't
have cameras the
size of my thumb
like we do now that we
could just drop down
that little jiffy drill hole.
It was easier to take a
student, or somebody like George
or myself, and drop
us down a bigger hole.
And that's what we did.
So this is going to be a
little bit about that story,
how we got out there, and how we
started working in those lakes.
And the biggest
single problem that we
faced that first
year was how do you
get through six meters of ice
to study those ecosystems.
Now out in McMurdo Sound people
had been diving in the ocean
there for years, and
years, and years.
And this is actually
my favorite place
on the planet to go swimming.
The Antarctic ocean is
just stunningly beautiful
underwater.
And I've had the opportunity
to spend quite a bit of time
under the ice in McMurdo Sound,
and I would be there right now
doing it if I could.
It's just that great of a place.
It's easy to make a
dive hole in McMurdo.
You just take a
big track vehicle
out to where you
want to put the hole,
and this hydraulic
drill just pops up,
and it's got a 1 and 1/2
meter diameter bit on it,
you just pop it
over, and take off,
and about a half hour later
you've got a hole drilled,
and then you just
clear the ice out.
And then you can even
pull a little hut
over the top with
a heater inside.
You've got this
nice house that you
can sit in, get all your
dive gear on and everything,
and then go swimming.
The only thing you
have to do is share
the dive hole
occasionally with seals.
And of course that's
one of those things
that you have to be careful
about because there's not
a lot of room in a dive hole,
and if you've got to get out
and the seal's there
that can be a problem.
But it is an incredibly
gorgeous place underwater.
I just through love it.
It's filled with life, and the
lighting is just beautiful,
and there's ice, anchor
ice, all over the bottom.
There's frazil ice underneath
the sea ice itself.
It's one of those
things that if you
get to watch some of the
videos that are online
and on BBC right now you should
definitely do it if you can.
Now, back in the early '90s
we had a Telepresent Rover
that we were using.
We actually had this Rover
connected back to NASA Ames
by satellite so that we could
control it through Ames so they
could make virtual
dives with me.
So Butler Hine and several
others, Michael Sims,
over at Ames would actually
go swimming with me
while they were in their office.
And I would be 11, 12,000
miles away underwater
underneath the ice.
And we also had the opportunity
to turn that episode
into an EPO opportunity.
And we had students in
California, Hawaii and Virginia
also drive this vehicle and take
virtual dives with me as well.
So this was in November
of 1993, and at that time
I was actually pulling together
a little program called
Dale's Dive Diary.
And we were pumping this up
through Quest here at NASA Ames
on to the very, very
new web at the time.
So we've been kind to
actively involved in trying
to blog and get our stories
out since the first time
that we could actually do it.
And this was actually the first
time any broadcast like this
had been made from
the Antarctic.
So we're going to go
to the Dry Valleys now.
This is Taylor Valley.
You're looking at
Lake Bonney here.
And that's the Taylor Glacier at
the bottom part of the screen.
And that's looking out
towards Ross Island,
and in the very,
very background you
can see the volcano popping
up as the island warms around
where McMurdo's at.
This is a typical
campsite for us.
This is where Alfonso, Chris,
and I stayed a few years ago
in 2009, 2010, in Pearse Valley.
And again, it's one
of the most Mars
like environments on the planet.
It's a very, very
dry, cold desert.
And just off to the
left there's a lake,
and this is the
surface of that lake.
This is Lake Joyce.
And it has about six
meters of ice on top of it.
It's very rugged surface.
And we kept our
camp up on the top,
but we kept a working
cam down on the ice.
And here you can see a dive hut
to the left and a science tent
on the right, and the tripod is
right where the dive hole is.
But first we have to
make some small holes.
And this is how we make those
small jiffy drill holes.
And this is the same
thing that people
would use for ice fishing
in standard temperate lakes
during the winter
time, but we end up
with a lot more bit
on the top of it.
So that makes it pretty easy
getting in those small holes,
but then that came
to the problem of OK,
how do you make a bigger hole?
And traditionally chainsaws
had been used to cut out ice.
But you know, you can't do
that through six meters,
which is 20 feet of ice.
You'd have to start the
hole out really, really wide
and then work your way
down to the bottom.
Finally, somebody would have
to get down to the bottom
and chop that piece
out, and that just
didn't seem like
a very good idea.
And it had to be moving
a lot of ice to do that.
So we came up with a
pretty elegant solution.
We took some copper
tubing and formed it
into a coil, like a hot plate.
Well, actually I'll show
you that in a second.
But we use a steam cleaner to
heat the water up and circulate
it.
This is a standard, off the
shelf, Hotsy steam cleaner.
You can see it's been
modified a little bit.
The hooks and
everything on it are
so we can transfer
it by helicopter.
But then we have a
coil that we just
pass that hot fluid through.
We lay that down onto
the ice and let it melt.
And we have a little pump on
their to pump some of the water
off so that we keep most of
that heat being driven straight
into the ice as it's going down.
Now, sometimes we can't
use the copper coil,
so we have to use
a long cylinder.
And here we just drill a
jiffy drill hole all the way
through the ice, and we
lower this copper tubing
that you see here down
just below the ice level,
and then as it heats up it
convects the heat upward,
and it enlarges that jiffy
drill hole over time,
and it just gets bigger,
and bigger, and bigger.
There's pluses and minuses
to using both ways.
The nice thing about
using the flat coil
is you've got a dry hole, and
you can go down into the ice
as it's melting, which
is pretty phenomenal.
When you take a trip
down into that ice,
that ice is usually
about 10 years
for it to form at the bottom
and sublimate off the top
and turn over.
So it's a nice 10-year-old
voyage back in time
through the ice cover.
And you can do the stratigraphy.
You can take samples.
And it's a great place
to finally just catch up
on the news.
You know this is kind of
a slow time for the work.
You're just sitting there
watching and babysitting
the melter.
Or if it gets cold outside
and the wind starts blowing,
you can actually get
down in the hole,
and get on the copper
coil, and just enjoy
the warmth, which
is kind of nice.
But eventually you have
to get in the water.
Now, this was
going back to 1978.
And this was at a time
when we were still
trying to figure a lot
of these things out,
and a lot of the
technology for diving
hadn't caught up to
where it is today.
So we were still using
wetsuits at the time.
This was in November, in
Taylor Valley at [INAUDIBLE].
The outside temperatures were
probably minus 15 or minus 20.
It was probably a
windy day, like normal.
And we had just a
couple of small tents .
The tent on the right
was a tent that we
were sleeping in, eating
in, and diving out of.
And of course we
would have to walk out
onto the ice over to the dive
hole after we were outside,
taken all of our
clothes off, and getting
into these really thick
wetsuits, which was not easy.
Actually getting in to
the wetsuits and diving
wasn't so bad.
It was actually getting out
of the dive hole, getting out
onto the surface in
minus 20, and then
having the suit freeze up, and
then having to take it off.
That was actually the problem
with the diving at that point.
So here you can see
me as a youngster.
I was 22 years old
I started this.
And we were using double
hose regulators, which people
don't tend to see
very often anymore.
We were still using some
old buoy finzy buoyancy
compensators, and some
standard masks and things.
And of course we're tethered.
We've got a nylon line tied to
us and we were on rope signals.
That's one important
safety element here
is when you dive in these
lakes you have to be tethered
or you don't get
back to the hole.
But this is how
we changed things.
A couple years later Doc
Simmons finally got some money,
and we bought some dry suits.
These were really
quite nice to have.
These were Poseidon
uni-suits at the time .
And we also went over
to full face masks.
These are Kirby Morgan
KMB 10 full face
masks that have
communications inside,
and we'd wear them in sort of
a bailout mode most of the time
those years, or we had a
tank attached to our back,
and we just breathed in
regular like regular scuba.
And here you can see
me getting pulled out
kind of in that configuration.
Now, this is a leap
of another 10 years.
This is in the early '90s.
And we started switching
over to newer face
masks that are lighter weight.
And I'm still using
the same mask actually.
It's an Exo 26 by DSI.
And we've moved over to probably
more comfortable and easier
to use dry suits like the Dewey
suits that are available now.
This is a CF 200, since I've
got on a pair of twin 70's
for tanks, and again, you
can see a communication line
coming down to me
which, is also my guide
to get in and out of
the water, and allows
me to communicate
to the surface.
In recent years probably one of
the best things that's happened
is now we have these dry gloves.
And dry gloves really
make our ability
to function underwater
a lot nicer.
Because that's still the one
thing that we can't really
control very well is
losing heat from our hands.
Most the time in the dry
suits all the way back even
in the wetsuits back
late '70s I was never
really cold underwater,
but your hands
would get cold, especially
when we had the wet mitts on.
But with the advent of
the dry gloves, and now
we've got heating systems that
we can put into these things,
and that really helps us out.
And of course now we've
got some very nice huts
that we can use out on
the ice or in the field.
We can store our dive gear
inside, dry everything, hang up
our dive suits, make sure
that they're bone dry,
and keep our science
equipment happy.
And this is sort of our typical
set up in the Dry Valleys right
now.
We use surface supplied
air for our dives.
And you can see the rack
of tanks in the back.
And in the box on the right
we have an air compressor.
And then we open
up this yellow box
and it's our gas management
system and a comm. box.
So this is where the
tender would be standing,
or a dive supervisor
would be standing
to communicate with
the diver underwater
to help with safety
issues and also
to record the science
that's going on.
And then we have a tether.
In this case it's a
tether that allows air
to flow back and forth
on surface supplied.
And they're usually between 70
meters or a little bit more,
maybe 100 meters
depending on the tether.
But when you're that far
out it's a pretty long ways.
If you're a football
field length
out on a line
under the ice, when
you're that far away you've
got to ask yourself can
I swim back on one breath.
And usually that answer is no.
So that gives you
pause for thought
when you're that far out.
So what I want to
do now-- So that's
sort of the history
of where we've
gone over the years
in the Dry Valleys.
But I want to shift
gears a little bit
and go into a little more
detail about some of the work
that we're doing
in Lake Untersee.
And this is pretty cool
work that we started up
in 2008 with a very different
model for doing the research.
And this is our dive
logo from last year.
In fact, here's our research
team from this last season.
And Alfonso, who's here
in the audience with us,
is standing next to me on
the right hand side there.
And it's a fairly
international team.
We have normally
about six people
or so who go down with us.
I like to keep the
field teams small.
It's nice to be able to pick
from a known pool of people.
So we've work with
people over the years,
and we know who's reliable
in the field, who's
reliable with their skills,
you know if they're a diver
or if they're a
climber, or if they're
good at one particular
set of skills
it's nice to be able to
count on them for doing that.
And again, it's
very international.
This last few seasons we've had
people from Russia, Australia,
New Zealand, Canada, and this
next season we'll probably,
if we're lucky, have some people
from Japan coming with us.
The selection of
people and individuals
really is dependent
on the kind of science
that we're doing
at any given time.
But I really prefer
to have individuals
that we've worked
with before, or have
had people that had
worked with us that
had had other experiences with
other people that we know,
so that we can
understand how they're
going to operate in the field.
And sort of the additional
things that we looked for,
so in addition to
your science skills,
you know we're
looking for people
that have a multi-dimensional
capability to them.
So we want them to have other
tools in their tool kit.
They've got to be skilled at
doing a diverse set of things,
like being able to dive,
or being able to climb,
understanding how to
operate in cold conditions,
and understanding how to
work in those conditions.
And those are all
things that you
don't come to just naturally.
It's something that takes
time and effort to learn.
And learning how to operate
in these environments safely,
and being able to
count on one another
is something that's
really paramount to us.
And so I want people
that can work in a group
or work individually.
If we've got a little
problem we want
to be able to send somebody
off and just say, go puzzle
this out, and figure
it out, you know
don't bother us for a
while, just get it done,
and you expect that to happen.
We want people that know
when it's time to talk
and when it's time to listen,
when it's time to lead
and when it's time to follow.
And those are also very
important skill sets
that are applicable
in everyday life,
but they're really, really
important for us out
in the field.
And it's really
important to have
a person that knows how
to tie the right knot
at the right time, which
kind of sums it up.
So our journey to
Lake Untersee starts
in Cape Town, South Africa.
That's where the team
assembles, and we
all board an Ilyushin 76.
And this is an interesting
project in that unlike the work
we do in the
McMurdo Dry Valleys,
where we're typically supported
through NASA or the National
Science Foundation and
participate in the US Antarctic
program, in this case we're
totally privately funded
but we're also embedded in
the Russian Antarctic program.
So it's an interesting mix of
how we go about the funding
process and getting down
there to do the work.
ALCI is a company that formed
from some of the people that
arrived in that area after the
breakup of the Soviet Union.
And they decided
that their skill
set was that they knew how to
do logistics in polar regions,
and so they set up the company
ALCI to provide logistics
in the Queen Maud Land
region, and they service now
as a nonprofit company.
The [INAUDIBLE] community,
which is about 13 countries.
And then also
there's another side
of the company that
deals with some
of the tourism that's picked up.
But we jump inside
this aircraft,
and it's about a six hour flight
to get down to Novo station.
We land on a
prepared ice runway.
And this is actually a pretty
good piece of technology
to be able to build
a runway that's
safe to land on in these
kind of environments,
and the Russians have been
doing it for a very long time,
and they're very good at that.
And again, ALCI's
ice runway is the hub
for Queen Maud Land
for many countries,
like the UK, Japan, Belgium,
South Africa, of course Russia,
and a number of others.
Our first piece
of business to do
is to actually
unload the aircraft.
That's part of our deal.
As soon as the plane
lands we don't walk off
to some little hut
to go get coffee.
We walk to the back
of the jet and start
unloading the entire aircraft,
and in particular look
for the stuff that you
brought down, and pile it up,
and get it over to where
it's supposed to go.
And again, we're guests at
Novolazarevskaya Station,
the Russian station at
Schirmacher Oasis, which
has been there operationally
since about IGY.
I think it was built
in 1960 or '61.
And again, the environment
of the Antarctic,
so it's always cold.
And unlike what you
typically think,
sometimes it's
not brutally cold.
Sometimes our temperatures are
not in the minus 40's and minus
50's.
In fact, most of the time
that we're there we're
in the summertime, and the
temperatures are typically
cold when we first get there.
And in this case, Lake
Untersee in Schirmacher Oasis
is fairly north in
terms of the Antarctic,
and our mean annual temperature
in this area is about minus 10.
So we see minus 10's and minus
15 C's while we're there.
And then the temperatures
creep up towards freezing
during the summer months.
Light, it's usually
by the time we
get there it's light
24 hours a day.
So we do have to
worry about that
and how it effects
our working cycle.
And that's very important for
us to try to stay on track,
so we won't start drifting.
You don't want individuals
on your team drifting off
in different time schedules so
that all of sudden everybody's
waking up at different times.
So that's another important
part of the work that we do.
Medical care, we
have to understand
where we can get
some medical care.
We can get some at Novo station.
But for the diving
aspects of this,
our nearest
re-compression chamber
is in South Africa, which is a
six, seven hour flight away one
way.
So a jet would have to
come down, take us back,
and then of course,
we would have
to get in from the
mountains of Queen Maud Land
into the iced runway to
get on that jet again.
So it's a non-trivial
process if we have a problem.
And then the same hazards
that you typically expect,
you know falling
through crevices,
getting stuck in really bad
weather outside in storms.
And then we have the
physical isolation.
Once we're put out into our
field site the six of us
are pretty much on our own.
You know, we don't
have any contact
other than calling into the Novo
Station a couple times a day
to let them know that we're OK.
Otherwise, we're totally
apart from everybody.
We're isolated.
And we don't have
contact with anybody
other than through a low
bandwidth Iridium phone.
But before we go
out there, we have
to assemble all of our gear.
So we have some gear
that we store down there.
We have tents.
And we've got sleeping bags,
and snowmobiles, and things.
And we spend a couple of
days getting organized
and pulling all this gear
together, and preparing it
for transport.
And that's actually
a pretty big effort.
And as I get older and older
I find that that recovery
from having to do this
kind of hard labor--
Because we're not actually
scientists I think.
I think we're just movers.
We just move things
from pole to pole.
And it's always heavy things.
But we end up taking this trip.
And in the upper
part of the screen
you'll see Schirmacher Oasis.
And that's about
30 kilometers long.
And if you can see the little
light blue line in there
that's actually our GPS track
that goes across the ice
and inland into the mountains
over to Lake Untersee.
And you'll see that
line go down a glacier,
and then it hits the lake
that you can see down
at the bottom right
part of the screen.
So that's our road
to Lake Untersee.
It takes about
six to eight hours
to make that trip over the ice
by snowmobile, or by truck,
or track vehicle.
And again, that depends on the
weather, and the conditions,
and the visibility.
And this is where we're going.
This is a satellite image map of
Lake Untersee and Lake Oversea.
You can see the Anuchin Glacier
makes this really nice sloping
road right down to the
lake's surface, which
is quite nice for us because
we can literally drive down
that glacier right
on to the lake ice.
And that's the main place that
we've been doing our work.
In the upper right hand side
you can see Lake Oversea.
And this is where we
were camped last year.
We wanted to do a comparison
with Lake Oversea to Lake
Untersee, and we found
we were able to get up
to Oversea for a season to
do that work this last year.
Another part of work in
this area, of course,
is the whole history of
working in the Antarctic,
because it's only been
very short period of time
that people have
actually been working
down there since its discovery.
You know, it's only been
within a couple of generations
that these places have been
worked and actually visited
by people.
So in this area
it was the Germans
who discovered Schirmacher
Oasis in the mountains
in Queen Maud Land on the third
German Antarctic Expedition
back in 1938.
It was during part of the build
up of the war effort for them,
and they were actually
trying to find areas
that they could put
in whaling stations
so they could get
whale oil to help
their industrial processes.
And during that
work they came in,
and they found the mountains.
And that was the first time
that this lake was photographed
was in 1938, 1938 and 1939.
It wasn't mapped really
until the Soviets came back
in during IGY, and
then the Norwegians
came in a little while
later and started
doing the more serious aerial
photography of the area.
But this lake wasn't
visited by a person
until 1969, which I
think is kind of cool.
Just the same time the first
time we went to the moon.
So I've always thought
that was kind of nice.
And then more
recently there's been
extensive work done by some
of the Germans and Russians,
and others in the '80s.
And we've kind of taken over
the place for the last few years
going back off
and on since 2008.
You know, we've made
four trips there sense.
AUDIENCE: What
does SAE stand for?
DALE ANDERSON: The question
was what does SAE stand for.
And it's the Soviet
Antarctic Expedition.
So the SAE is Soviet
and the RAE is Russian
after it switched over
in the early '90s.
But this is where
this site is located.
These are some of the
mountains that you
find in this area
of Queen Maud Land.
And it's stunningly
beautiful mountains.
It's truly just
magnificence defined,
looking at these spires of
rock coming up out of the ice
like they do.
And this is our trip.
So we literally start going
across this barren wasteland
of blue ice and
snow, and we do have
to worry about crevices
as we're going out.
In particular, there
are several areas
that are laden with crevices,
and it takes us several hours
to get across those spots.
And usually we end
up pulling the trucks
out a dozen or so times
by the time we get out,
and hopefully without
breaking anything.
Occasionally we break the
wheels or things fall off
and we have to put them back on.
But here you can see one of the
trucks has got a tire stuck,
and the other truck has
moved over in front of it,
and is using the winch
to pull it back out.
Now oddly enough, last year
we had this same scenario
take place.
The truck got stuck.
Actually I was in one truck
and Alfonso was in the other.
And so my truck got stuck.
And Alfonso's truck
pulled out in front of us
and went around to come up
in front to put the winch on.
And they were a
pretty good ways away,
and their truck got stuck.
So we were just really
fortunate enough
that the winches from both
trucks reached to one another
and we were able to
pull each other out.
Otherwise it would
have been a long day.
But we also have
to snowmobile out.
So this is actually one of the
funner parts of the trip for me
I think is skidooing out
into the mountains like this,
and it's a really
unique and intimate way
to learn how to live in the
cold and work in the cold
is when you ride skidoos
in the Antarctic like this.
But eventually we
all get to the lake.
The trucks arrive.
They dump all of our gear off.
And the trucks depart.
And we have to set up
our camp and start work.
And this is really,
really an important part
of the trip right at this very
moment, because our support has
left, we're on our own,
and now the first thing
that we have to do
is get shelter up
very quickly, because this area
is really prone to high winds.
So we need to have
at least one tent up.
It usually takes
us about three days
to get the camp
fully established.
But if we don't get
that first tent up,
or two tents up, or as
many as we can get up
depending on how tired we
are and the timing of when
we arrive, we could get
nailed by really bad weather,
and we'd be spending it out
in the rocks instead of inside
in a tent.
But once the tent's established,
the camps established,
we have a pretty
nice home, and that's
where we live for the
next six to eight weeks.
And again, it's just a
really stunning backdrop.
The lake is completely ringed
by these large mountains.
And these mountains are all
composed of an [INAUDIBLE]
site, which plays an important
role in controlling some
of the chemical features,
for example the lake water.
But here it is.
This is a true example of
a land of rock and ice.
This is the surface
of Lake Untersee.
So we've got 2 and 1/2 to 3 and
1/2 meters of ice on the lake.
And we've also got probably
several hundred boulders.
Some of these
boulders are larger
than the snowmobiles, maybe
two, three times as large
as the snowmobile that
have worked their way out
on to the ice, and are
floating on that ice surface.
So it's not too often that you
get to see floating boulders.
This is our tent
camp from last year.
I just wanted to
give you an example
of how we establish the camp
and why we put it up this way.
I took my personal
drone down with me.
The DGI loaned me a Phantom
to take down with me,
so I've got a Phantom
with a Go-Pro on it,
and shot some
aerials of our camp.
And you can see that we've got
a science tent in the back.
We've got our cook
tent and the dive tent.
And then we've got some
individual sleeping tents,
a toilet tent, and
then some sundry gear,
and some small generators.
But this is our home and
this is how we establish it.
And we work in and
out of it like this.
And again, it's important
to maintain that schedule
that we have.
So we try to stay on
schedule for breakfast
in the mornings, kind of a
lunch, snack time whenever
we want it, working
around work, and then we
try to come in for a dinner
time around 6 o'clock or so.
But it's really
also very important
that we have a place
to retreat into.
We keep heat on in a couple of
these facilities like the dive
tent, we have to keep heat on to
keep some of the dive gear dry.
The science tent
has to have heat
so we can keep some of our
equipment and our science
samples from freezing at times.
And then it's really
important to keep the people
from freezing too, so with the
cook tent is another key place
that we have to have heat that
we can come into and get out
of the cold from time to time.
Now, we do monitor the climate.
And that's a very
important part of our job.
It's both so we can monitor
climate change in this area,
but it's also so that
we can understand
how climate affects
the lake ecosystem.
These are physically
driven ecosystems,
and that ice cover is
probably the key thing
that impacts the
ecosystem underneath it.
And of course that's
all climately driven,
how thick that ice is
and how long it lasts.
And this is the kind of
weather that we do tend to see.
And if we have
time, I'll show you
a quick video towards
the end that'll
demonstrate this
a little bit more,
but we do see pretty heavy
winds from time to time.
The temperatures wax and wane,
but our mean annual temperature
in this area is, like I
said, about minus 10 degrees
C. So that's not so bad.
It's really the winds that
make the working there
a little harder.
So when it's really windy
outside and it's cloudy
that's those difficult days
for us to work outside.
Now, it's interesting to compare
this area with the McMurdo Dry
Valleys.
These are Alpine lakes.
Lake Untersee is at about
560 meters in altitude,
and Lake Oversea is
about 800 meters.
So they're Alpine lakes
but a little higher up.
The McMurdo Dry Valleys
are a little further south
towards the south pole.
We're a little further
north at Lake Untersee.
The McMurdo Dry
Valleys though, if you
look at their
hydrological cycle,
it's really based on melt.
So when the peak temperatures
during the summers
come up just above freezing
the glaciers tend to melt off.
That liquid water drains
down into the valleys
and replenishes the
water for the lakes.
That seems pretty
easy to imagine,
and it's the way it works there.
In the Untersee area
it's a little different.
We don't see melt.
The evaporation rates are so
high that sublimation really
is the dominant feature here.
So we don't see melt
running off the glacier.
As a matter of fact, that's
why we can actually drive down
the glacier, because if
the glacier was melting
we would have these large
melt channels in it.
Otherwise, we have this nice
smooth road coming down,
where the winds have ablated
it off and kept it smooth.
It's the same with the ice.
It ablates very quickly
off the surface.
So we don't have
any melt streams
coming into these lakes.
It's one of the quirky things
that we noticed when we first
arrived there and other
people had noticed.
Where's the water come from?
There's no melt
streams that come
in during the height
of the summer.
So it's obviously coming
in from sub-glacial melt
and the front of the glacier.
The Anuchin Glacier
is actually moving
into this lake at a constant
rate of several meters
per year, and that water
that comes in as ice
melts and adds to the
water of the lake.
And then there's probably
also sub-glacial melt
coming from beneath
the glacier as well.
So it's a very
different process,
and it has a bigger impact on
how this ecosystem operates.
And you can see that this
is sort of a cartoon cross
section of Lake Untersee we've
got the Anuchin Glacier over
on the left.
We have a deep basin that goes
down to about 170 metres or so.
We don't know the
exact deepest point,
but that's the deepest
reported so far.
Then it comes up a slope out
in front of the peninsula
where we camp, and where
we have our med station.
And then it drops back down
into another anoxic basin
on the other side that
drops to about 100 meters.
And this is a really,
really cool lake.
AUDIENCE: If the average
temperature is below freezing
where does the heat source
come that keeps the water
liquid over long
periods of time?
DALE ANDERSON: Right,
so the question
is what's the heat
source for keeping
the place liquid over time
if the average temperature is
minus 10?
Well, it's the average
temperature, not
the peak temperature.
So you do have peak temperatures
coming up above freezing
at times.
But it's also solar heating.
So it's all solar driven.
So the sunlight is
the big driver here.
So the ice cover actually
traps the heat inside as well.
So once you've got the ice
cover there as freeze up takes
place the latent
heat pushes back down
and keeps that
heat budget going.
So you'll never freeze it
down solid unless it really
gets cold for a long,
long period of time.
But the water again is
very, very transparent,
which comes back to driving
that heat into the lake.
And we see quite a bit
of the light penetrating
through the ice cover.
We get around 5% in this lake
ice to get through the ice.
And then we can
probably get some
of that light down
to at least 130
to 140 meters, or
probably even deeper.
We found microbial
mats growing at a depth
of 160 meters in this
mat photosynthetically.
It's an interesting lake also
because the water pH is up
high.
It's 10.6, which is
kind of unusual for some
of these lakes.
But what really sets
this lake off apart
from a lot of the other lakes
is in that anaerobic basin,
down below about 80 meters, from
80 meters down to 100 meters,
the methane levels
just go crazy,
and you get dissolved
methane in this lake
at 20 millimole, which
is very, very unusual.
There's only a few places
around the planet where
you can get dissolved
methane levels that high.
There's some rift
lakes in Africa,
like Lake Kivu, that
has that in that lake.
And then also right on
top of methane clathrates
in the ocean, right at that
surface above the methane
clathrates you'd see
values like that.
So it's very unusual that
you see this much methane
production in a lake.
And just as an example,
if you took a one liter
bottle down the
bottom, 100 meters,
opened it up, filled
it up with that water,
and brought it to the
surface, and opened it,
you'd get about a half a
liter of methane out of it.
So it's a pretty
substantial amount of gas.
In fact, you could
plumb it with a pipe,
bring that pipe to the surface,
and then burn it if you wanted.
Now, the whole volume of gas
in there's not a huge amount,
so you'd burn it out
pretty quickly, which
wouldn't be a cool thing
to do for the lake,
but interesting to think about.
So this is our
typical kind of a day.
We have to drill
holes, melt holes,
saw the holes to get
in to make them bigger,
break the ice out to
get a little bigger,
and then jump into the water.
So that's the kind
of work that we
do, that once we get
the holes opened up then
we can really start
our work, whether it's
with a sampling device, an
instrument, or the divers
doing some specific cast.
But here we are.
This is Chris McKay
and myself getting
ready to continue through
a hole that we've already
been working on
at Lake Untersee.
Every time we get down a
little farther into the ice
we have to pull the thing
out, add a bit to it,
and put it back into
it to keep extending
the length of the drill bit.
And here we are making the
final push down through the ice.
And again, sometimes you
have to be very perseverant,
and teamwork is a really
important part of the deal
here.
So everybody's got to
work together and know
how to work with one another.
So this is coming
underneath the ice,
and I just want to talk about
the freeze up part again.
So another interesting
part about this score
with the gases, it's not
just the methane being high,
but all the other dissolved
gases, the air group gases
are very high as well.
And so if you look at the
underneath surface of the ice
you'll see these pockets.
And these are gas
pockets that have formed.
As freeze up takes
place underneath the ice
the gas molecules are too large
to fit in the ice lattice,
and they're pushed back
into the water column.
So it's sort of
like a bicycle pump
pumping up the gases
is in the lake.
And eventually the
dissolved gases
will nucleate and form bubbles
just underneath the ice.
And some of these bubbles
get very, very large,
and in particular, in this
lake they get very large.
They'll get 10's
of meters across.
You'll get pools of
gas underneath the ice.
And some of that
gas will actually
get entrained in
the ice, and I'll
show you the result of
that here right now.
This is actually
at Lake Oversee.
Let's see if you can hear this.
No.
OK well, this is at
Lake Oversee last year.
Alfonso and I went out to
drill one of the holes,
and we drilled down
through it, and we
knew we were going to get a
little bit of water coming up,
but we didn't realize we were
going to get quite so much.
This was actually enough
water to blow the drill out
of the hole.
So we were holding onto
it, and Alfonso finally
asked me what to do.
And we turned it off.
The drill actually
started reverse drilling
as fast as it was going
when it was turned on,
just cause the water
pressures was pushing it
up the other direction.
And we finally let
go, got the drill out.
We were standing inside
this fountain of water
probably for 10
minutes or so as we
were trying to deal
with the drill.
And there's Alfonso for scale.
This thing blew water
like this and gas
for I don't know, another hour,
to three hours at that height.
And then it kind of dribbled
out over the next several days.
So there's a huge pool
of gas sitting right up
underneath the ice here, that
will get replenished again as
soon as more gas comes into
the lake, which there's
a really good source of it
The Anuchin Glacier of course
is glacial ice and
glacial ice has
a lot of entrained
bubbles in it,
and that gas is basically gets
delivered right into the lake.
So it's like an air stone
coming into the lake
essentially, adding
that much volume of gas
to the lake every year.
But then it's time to
get into the water.
So we keep a portable compressor
out in the field with us,
and then we fill up the
tanks, and get everything set,
and then it's time to get in.
So at Lake Untersee
we'll usually skidoo over
to our dive site,
get dressed out.
And here I am sporting my new
dry gloves, these Kubi Rings,
which were really quite nice.
It's another one of
these things when
you're diving,
you're always trying
to find the nicest thing
that you can put on,
the easiest thing that
you can deal with.
And so far the Kubi Rings, which
are really quite nice for me,
have shown me that I can get
in and out of those ring sets
very easily, even when I'm cold.
Sometimes you can get
these dry glove rings on,
but sometimes you can't
get them off very easily.
And these Kubi's work
quite nicely for that
and they don't leak.
So then down we go.
We head on down.
Normally we dive only with one
person under the ice at a time,
because it's more difficult
to have two people in,
especially if you have
an accident or a problem,
and you'd have to have
both divers coming up
out of the hole at once.
And there's not very
much room in the hole.
So as long as we're
on tether, as long
as we've got good
communications,
and there's no obstructions
underneath the water,
we're pretty comfortable
with diving by ourselves.
And that's been the policy of
our diving in the US Antarctic
program in these lakes now for
a better part 25 years or more,
and it's worked
out quite nicely.
But on this occasion I
wanted to get some shots.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
DALE ANDERSON: Yeah, we
don't go to that deep.
I'll get to that in a second.
The question is since we've
measured the depths down
to 170 meters and 100
meters in both the basins,
do we get down that deep?
And only instruments
and sampling devices
go down to those depths.
The divers are 40
meters or above.
So 130 feet is the
deepest that we can go.
And we dive very conservatively.
Again, it comes back
to if we have problems,
like if we get bent, or
if we have an embolism,
we're going to be in bad shape.
We can go on to
oxygen in the field,
and we can do some
basic first aid,
but it's a long trip to
get back to South Africa.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] your own
air and not any [INAUDIBLE]?
DALE ANDERSON: Right.
So the question is
what gas do we use?
We use air.
One, we don't really
need any other advantage,
in terms of nitrox it would
give us for time at depth.
What we really just need
is a very simple way
to compress our air.
And if we had
nitrox, you know we'd
have to mix the gas as well.
So we don't want
to have to do that.
And for us the cold
is a bigger driver
then-- You know, typically
the diver will get cold
before you'd run out of
gas, unless we're really
going down deep, and
then nitrox doesn't
make a difference anyway.
So we're just on air.
But in this case
I wanted to take
some shots of a diver
doing some work.
So I got in with Ian one time.
Ian went down to take
some core samples.
So that gave a little
bit of perspective.
Now, this particular
shot is the bottom
of the lake at Lake Untersee.
And there's two
features here that
really pop out very quickly.
One, it's dominated
on the bottom
by these large
conical stromatolites.
And this is the first
time this has ever
been documented in a lake.
And its relatives go back
about 3 and 1/2 billion years
in the fossil record.
So it's a pretty
unusual find for us,
and it's a really exciting find.
Now, if you look up
underneath the ice,
way off in the distance, you
can see one of those big gas
bubbles I was talking about.
That's a pool of gas
that's probably 15 to 20,
or 30 meters across that's just
waiting to get up into the ice
and have us drill into
it one of these years.
But here's another example of
these conical stromatolites.
Ant it is, it's really a
world that we've never seen.
So we've seen their
fossil relatives
in the ancient sediments
of the Pilbara region
for example in
Western Australia.
But we haven't seen
modern examples,
and this is the
only place that we
know of where these large
conical stromatolites are
forming in a modern setting.
If you look at the
coloration on them
you'll see that they're
kind of that purplish hue,
that nice pinkish
purplish hue, and that's
the phycoerythrin, which
is the dominant pigment
for their photosynthesis
capability.
And that's helping them to
collect the light level,
or the quality of
light that's coming
through the ice, the
nice blue light that's
coming down to them.
It's tuned to that light level.
And they're very, very
efficient at what they do.
They can use every
little bit of sunshine
that comes down through
that ice to make a living.
And we've got some
of these same players
that we see in a lot of the
other lakes that we work in.
Phormidium and leptolyngbya
are the two big guys.
And interestingly there's
no diatoms in these lakes.
And we don't still
quite know why
that is, whether it's something
special in the chemistry that's
keeping them from
being there, or it's
just because they're
geographically isolated
and they haven't
gotten there yet.
But it's probably a
combination of several things.
But it also may have
an-- We see diatoms
in all the other
Antarctic lakes that we've
worked in for the most part.
There's a few pockets that
there's reports of no diatoms.
But all of those other
lakes, none of them
have these large conical
stromatolites growing.
So we think that may play a
role in the morphologies that
are developing in
this particular lake.
Maybe the absence of diatoms
helps the cyanobacteria
form the kinds of
structures that they want
versus what the diatoms
help them make later.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] this
conical shaped [INAUDIBLE].
DALE ANDERSON: Yeah, so
the modern stromatolites
that we see are microbial mats.
These are cyanobacterial
mats that are actively
forming these dome
shaped structures.
And they're laminated
inside, and I'll
show you that here in a second.
These are the same
photosynthetic mats
that we see at 160 meters.
And you can see that
they're that very rich pink,
phycoerythrin rich color.
And that's where those accessory
pigments are helping them
to harvest the light
that's available,
even those one or two
little photons that
are getting down to that depth.
Now, if you take one of
these conical stromatolites
that we've got and you slice it
in half this is what you see.
You can see that
it's very laminated.
And in the McMurdo Dry
Valleys over the years
Ian [? Haas ?] and some others
have finally figured out
that most of what we
see are annual layers.
Layers like this are laid
down every single year.
Here, once we came
back and we did
some of the radiocarbon dating
to see how old this thing was,
the relative dates between
just a few centimeters
apart was upwards
of 2,500 years.
And so the math didn't
work out for a yearly
or an annual deposition, but
it's more of a decadal scale.
So it's taking a long time
to build these things up.
And that makes sense because
there's very, very little
sediment that we
see in these waters.
So these formations
take a pretty long while
to get to where they're at.
Again, the question
is does it actually
take 2,500 years to build
this little tiny conical
stromatolite that
we've got here?
OK, here's just a
couple of shots of this
is sort of again the
typical work that we do.
That really does
transport us back in time.
Here's Ian taking
those core samples,
and you can see that
they're little tiny plugs.
Also, notice how gently
Ian is on the bottom.
So this is another really
big part of the training
that we have to do for
working in these lakes.
These lakes are very
delicate, and we
don't want to disturb
the microbial mat
systems very much.
So you have to really understand
how to control your buoyancy.
And that's a real skill.
It's actually a
difficult skill to learn,
and most people don't
pick up on it very easily.
But here you can see that the
only thing that are touching
are the tips of his
fins on one side
and where his hand is
picking up the core,
and then you can see the
core box over on the side.
So we make sure that the
areas that we disturb
are really minimized by
working hard to do that.
Now again, if you went back in
time 3 and 1/2 billion years
ago, and Chris, Alfonso and I
did this a couple years ago.
We went over to
Western Australia
into the Pilbara region.
And this is sort of a
mecca for astrobiologists
because this is one of the
areas where you can go,
it's one of the very few areas
on the planet Earth today
where the rocks haven't been
folded back into the earth
and put into the
furnaces so to speak
and had the records removed.
It's one of the few places
where you can go back and find
sedimentary rocks that date
back 3 and 1/2 billion years,
and find evidence
of life in them.
So what you're looking at here
are some conical stromatolites
that are preserved
in that record.
The one on top is about
a billion .8 years old,
and then the two
over on the right
are 3 and 1/2 billion years
almost over in an area
that we visited.
So those are actually
outcrops in the rocks
that we saw and
photographed at the time.
And you can see the three
dimensional cones in the lower
one, the lower right,
are a great match
up for the conical stromatolites
that we have in the lake.
So what I'm going to do is I'm
going to just really briefly go
through a few tools of the trade
that we've got just so you can
see some of the things
that we work with,
and then I'll be wrapping
it up here pretty quickly.
But this is the typical
stuff that we use.
We'll take sediment cores.
We have light meters, oxygen
and pH meters, conductivity,
temperature, depth meters.
We use flourometers
to help us understand
how the microbial mats are
able to photosynthesize
under the conditions
that they're in.
And then we have these
underwater micro sensors
that allow us to check
for pH and oxygen levels
down inside the mats at a very,
very high resolution scale.
And then of course
we've got cameras.
And the LIDAR system
is actually a unit
that we've used once
to paint the bottom.
And it gives us a
three dimensional image
of the bottom of lake.
And these are some of the
things that we take down.
So this is the PAM
flourometer that we take down.
And again, you have to come
down and place these things
into a certain position
without tearing the place apart
and actually tearing
apart the study
site that you're
trying to study.
And it's difficult to do that.
It looks like it's
easy, but it's not,
because you're on a tether.
You've got big
weights on your belt.
You're carrying
equipment with you.
You've got the buoyancy
control issues.
So it's a real skill set to get
these things down and put them
in place properly.
This is the micro
electrode system.
And what you see here is
a box over on the side
that will record the data
and take the measurements.
And then over on
the left hand side
you see the micro
electrode that's
been attached to a
stage micrometer.
And we can actually push
this little fine needle,
at the very end it's thinner
than a human hair, down
into the microbial mats at
a half a micron increment.
And this is actually the
coldest work that we did,
because as a diver you
sit down at the bottom
and all you do is move
your fingers very slowly
over a period of anywhere
from 30 minutes to an hour.
And that's where your hands
just really get pretty cold.
And that's why the new
electrically heated gloves
are probably going to be real
help for this kind of work
in the future.
This is an example of the LIDAR.
So you'll notice here that
we've got a lift bag on it.
So when we use tools
like this-- Actually this
is the same version of that
little micro electrode system,
but it's an automated system.
But it's large
enough that we have
to use a lift bag to pull
it over into the spot
that we want it, gently lower
it down, and then use it
from the surface.
It's really nice to do it
that way from the surface,
but it's also difficult
getting the thing in place.
So there's trade offs on
using this kind of technology
as well.
There's the LIDAR system.
Again, it's is a
large item that we
have to take down with a lift
bag and put in place gently.
And then it paints the
area with a green laser,
and gives us that
three dimensional
map of those microbial
mats on the bottom.
And then there's this
very simple stuff.
This is just Plexiglas tubes.
And these are things
that we stick down
into the dirt to
collect samples.
And there we go, back to home.
But after we're
done with the dives,
then we have to take
the samples back,
and we have to take them back
into the lab and process them.
So there's quite a bit
of work left afterwards.
And that's sort of the end of
the day for us is coming in,
and finished up the samples,
and then checking on the camp,
then going back in to dinner,
and getting ready for bed.
So what I want to do right now
is just show a quick video.
And I don't know if there's
audio on here or not.
We'll see.
And this will kind of
sum up a little bit
of what we've been seeing.
And there's no audio.
And this is just a panorama
around a little bit
of the area.
And just briefly, this is
New Zealand [INAUDIBLE].
This is just an example of some
of the whether that we see.
So this is not a
too, too bad day.
This is actually with winds that
are only about 45 or 50 knots.
When they're blowing
at close to 100 knots
that's when we have to really
be a little more careful.
And we have measured
winds creeping up
to 50 meters per second, which
is around 112 miles an hour.
We have lost tents in the field.
Sometimes the winds
come down, and they're
just like bowling
balls hitting the tent.
And they'll just
flatten one tent.
Like two years ago, I
was sitting in my tent,
and a couple minutes later
the tent was sitting on me.
So we do have to keep
extra tents outside.
And during these times
you can't be actually
inside the tent
most of the time.
Quite often you have to be
outside looking at everything
to make sure the
tents don't blow away.
So again, it's nice to
be in a comfortable tent
when it's in a storm.
On the other hand, you don't
want your gear to blow away
and you don't want your
tents to blow away,
so it's time to be outside
looking to make sure
that it's all safe and sound.
This is just sort of
the typical scenario
of getting dressed out at
the dive hole and jumping in.
You can see we're
putting on the weights.
I think that's actually Alfonso
in the back helping me out.
And just getting
suited up and going.
And then it's down through the
ice, and down to the bottom.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
DALE ANDERSON: Yeah, it
kind of varies where it is.
It depends on the part of
the season that you're in,
but sometimes you can
get a free board that's,
what, 30 centimeters
or so Chris?
So it can actually
be a fair-- That's
one of the reasons we take
chainsaws out and chainsaw
around the hole sometimes
to get the diver down
closer to the lip of the
water, to get in and out.
It makes getting in and
out a little easier.
But these are the
microbial mats that we see.
And they're just gorgeous.
And again, this is the
only place on the planet
that we know of where these
large conical stromatolites are
forming like this.
And these are all about
anywhere from a few centimeters
to half a meter tall.
So some of these things
are almost this tall
on the water, which
is pretty unusual.
Most of things that you
see in most environments
are the size of your finger
or a little bit bigger.
Maybe the size of your hand.
So this is a pretty
unique system.
And I'll just stop it there.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any idea what's
happening in the late
[INAUDIBLE] winter,
or how it change in the winter?
Or do you have any
plans to do that?
DALE ANDERSON: Yeah, so
the question is do we
know what's going
on in the winter?
And do we have any
plans of trying
to find out what's
going on in the winter?
Well, we do some of that.
So the biggest thing that we've
got that's out there full time
is the med station.
So the climate station has been
out there now for five years,
and we've got a really nice,
long five year data set.
And in fact, that's
the reason I came out
was to work on that
data set with Chris,
to publish a paper for it.
So that's the most important
thing that we leave right now.
There are some underwater
sensors and some devices
that we'd like to
leave underwater,
but we haven't pulled that off.
So that might be in the future.
It's a little more
difficult to do that.
And of course we have to ensure
that we get back every year,
or every so often
to get the data.
And that's another part
of the story too is,
you know, maintaining
funding, and trying
to get the funding
to keep us going,
and to get those tools
to leave underwater.
AUDIENCE: How long does it take
to drill a hole with the coil?
Can you show it to us
on the [INAUDIBLE]?
DALE ANDERSON: So
how long does it
take to make a dive hole
with one of the coils?
Well, a flat coil,
again, it depends
on how thick the ice is.
If it's 2 and 1/2
meters versus 6 meters
it'll obviously be
a big difference.
But in general we can
count on a day or two,
or maybe up to three
days to make a hole.
By the time we get it all
set up, and we open it up,
and water floods and
comes up to the surface,
and the hole's ready.
So it's a couple
of days at least.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
concerned about doing it
on a lake [INAUDIBLE]?
DALE ANDERSON: It is.
It's a real concern of ours.
It's like anything.
Any time you study
anything you're
going to change the
environment a little bit.
So you try to
minimize that change.
And one thing that
we do is, just
for example, everything that we
bring into the field with us,
everything, goes back out.
So all of our waste
goes back out.
We collect all human waste.
All the grey water that we
produce, all trash, everything.
That goes in and out with us.
For working in the lake itself,
over the years in the McMurdo
Dry Valleys we've wrestled
with this problem as well
and have come up with
suggestions and techniques that
help minimize that as well.
And part of that is keeping
the gear extremely clean
to make sure that we
don't transfer organisms
from system to
system for example.
Our impact is really pretty
minimal through these lakes.
Our scale is so much smaller
than the volume of water
that we're working in.
And again, we try
to minimize anything
that we do that would
disrupt anything.
AUDIENCE: Do you have to
re-open the holes every year,
or do they stay closed up?
DALE ANDERSON: Yeah,
they'll close up
over a period of weeks to months
they'll freeze shut again.
So every year we have
to open up a hole.
And depends on
when you're there.
If you're working in the
Dry Valleys for example,
in October or November,
a few days can pass,
and you'll have to go back
out and chip the hole out,
or chainsaw it out, depending
on how long you've left it.
But after a week you can
count on pretty thick ice
being back in the hole.
BORIS: All right.
That's all the questions.
So please join me
in thanking him.
DALE ANDERSON: Thank you.
Thank you.